I've been all through time.
It's freaking me out.
I always. He didn't know that I was lying.
It's terrible.
On October 5th, you've got about an hour.
You've got about 5 minutes.
Low key returns.
What's the plan to get
in an all new season.
final remark.
It's pretty spectacular.
Today was the first day that I wore
this costume to wear this thing.
It just feels enormously powerful.
Loki has been in the movies
for well over a decade now, and since day
one really won everybody over and became
one of our most beloved characters.
I am Loki of Asgard
and I am burdened with glorious purpose.
Your savior is here.
I remember as clear as day.
The first auditions for Thor were.
What am I?
What I loved about playing Loki
is he plays all the keys on the piano.
He could be fun comedic,
but also volatile and angry.
Tom Hiddleston is almost
wholly responsible
for Loki becoming an instant fan favorite.
Minor.
And that's why
we wanted to do a Loki show.
Welcome to the Time Variance Authority.
In that first run at it,
we've created something
bright and colorful and spectacular.
It's such a thrill to see that
audiences connected with this new world
in this new story.
Season two is building
and expanding upon that world.
I'm excited to be back.
Back in the TVA,
back with this amazing team.
We get to go further and take bigger risks
to create this endlessly
fascinating box of tricks.
And I feel excited
and inspired about where we go next.
Come on, you're the God of mischief.
Always have been
and always will be.
Welcome back everyone
It's Charlie.
They dropped a brand new Loki Season 2
trailer video
with a whole bunch of new footage.
So we'll break it all down.
There's a whole bunch of Easter eggs here.
I'll be doing episode videos
just like I did for season one.
Be sure to subscribe to get
everything also started doing that
giveaway for the Loki Blu rays.
All you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber
and just post all your predictions
based on the footage in the video.
the other great news
that you probably just saw in
your feeds is it
looks like the strike stuff
has mostly been figured out,
mostly on the writers side.
Right now they have to do the actors next,
but for the most part
they had the same issues.
So now that the studios work
things out with the writers,
they have a couple more weeks
to figure things out with the actors,
then it sounds like everything's
pretty much back to normal
by the middle of October,
which I think is what most people
expected, who understood what was going on
with all the strike stuff.
so if you wondered
why all the studios have been super quiet
about their big upcoming movies
and TV shows, like all the real big stuff
that's coming,
it's mostly because of the strike.
Now that that's over,
you start hearing news
about all the big stuff that's coming.
but just starting
with the brand new footage,
they have a couple more jokes
about Loki time slipping in.
Moby is completely freaking out like,
you look terrible.
I was lying.
does this scene of him
times flipping in front of that 1980s
McDonalds where Sylvie works,
which is probably how he finds out that
she's there hiding out in the first place.
are a couple scenes of him
trying to escape
the TVA at the beginning of the season.
This is like episode one footage of him
going on the run
because they don't believe him
when he says that he knows them.
remember the whole idea in episode one
is that he traveled back to a point
earlier in the TVA's timeline
closer to its creation.
So they haven't met him yet.
So they think that he's a normal anomaly,
like a normal variant
that they have to arrest and process
that's
why he's back in the prisoner uniform
trying to explain things to Mobius.
It's like,
No, no, no, we've met each other.
We've all done this before.
The reason why there's a King statue
in the TVA in place of the timekeepers
is because in this earlier
point of the TVA's existence,
he who remains wasn't hiding
what he was doing.
Like everybody knew
that he was running the TVA.
Then at some point later in the timeline,
he wiped all their minds
and just made them think that
it was the timekeepers. Instead.
There are couple scenes of Loki
interrogating the zany variant
that they tried to arrest.
Like you see him in the chair here
Look at Mobius in the background.
All proud of how Loki has grown up like,
Oh, now you're interrogating people to
not sure
what's going on with this weird portal.
Seem like the tiny portal with him
trying to, like, crouch down in it
For whatever reason,
they go back to that 1980s
McDonald's with him in tow
when they're finding Sylvie.
Not sure why he's there with them,
but they just have
a couple of McDonald's jokes
while they're there.
they're a couple more scenes of Victor
Time, Lee's version of Kang, helping them
save the timeline,
like Save the Multiverse,
which is a big twist on season one.
like, the whole idea is the Kang
variants are meant to be villains.
He's meant to be fighting them
or stopping them
from trying to destroy the multiverse.
But it seems like one of the big twists
of Loki Season two is that at least
this Kang variant Victor Timely Kang
will be helping them instead. no.
I think the idea is that not all Kang
variants are meant to be bad,
like some of them are meant to be helpful.
But supposedly the real villain of Loki
Season two will be a twist
on the Sylvie character.
Like during season one they did Richard E
Grant classic Loki character.
There's going to be a twist
on the Sylvie character.
Like older Sylvie, But supposedly it's
meant to be a future variant
of this version of Sylvie,
who's grown remorseful for all the things
that she and Loki have done to mess
with the timelines.
Messed with the multiverse.
so within the TVA agents here that are
all trying to fight Sylvie and Loki
here, that they're trying to stop
are actually working for the older Sylvie.
she's supposed to be played by Kate
Dickie.
Most of you remember her as Lysa Aaron
from the Game of Thrones series.
She was great at playing that batshit
crazy character on Game of Thrones.
So it'll be interesting to see
what she's like during the Loki series.
Let me know in the comments, though.
What do you think about the big twist
in the Council of Kings
won't be the actual main villain in Loki?
Season two. but.
There will be using the season to set up
what's happening during Deadpool
three because of all the crossover
with the TVA characters.
Supposedly Loki also films
some cameo scenes for Deadpool three
during that Deadpool
does something in a bunch more incursions
start happening like the multiverse
finally starts collapsing in on itself.
Then the TVA try to save as many people
as they can, putting them on battle world
from different universes.
And that's how you wind up
with your MCU version of Battle World
from the Secret Wars
Comics that battle world might wind up
being a version of the Void planet
where they just dump everything.
It just makes more sense
to use the void planet
because they already are pruning stuff,
sending it there.
like Sylvie purposely sent herself there
so that she could find Loki.
save. All your universes were collapsing.
That would be a really easy way
to save people,
just like automatically prune
as many people as you possibly could
to try and save their lives.
The couple.
The really cool moment
during this trailer, too,
where he talks about his original audition
for the first Thor movie.
Originally, he actually auditioned
for the Thor character.
This is what his
audition was. And remember,
you chose This is
for Outlander.
Doesn't it seem a little bit
less like we almost had a
Tom Hiddleston version of Thor?
Could you imagine all the Marvel movies
with the Tom Hiddleston Thor?
he's an amazing actor.
Like, he could have totally knocked
that out of the park.
But Kenneth Branagh supposedly
convinced him behind the scenes
that he would be better
for the Loki character.
And he should slimmed that like,
get less bulky and Chris Hemsworth
should go for Thor in bulk, up.
originally we also almost
had a Chris Hemsworth version of Loki.
Maybe they'll have some twist about that
in like a future season of Loki.
They do Loki Season three.
That would be crazy
to see a Chris Hemsworth version of Loki.
I think that all of us are happy
with the way things worked out, though.
Like we're much happy.
We're Tom Hiddleston, Loki but since then
they've had a lot of Easter eggs
referencing him
almost being Thor in the movies.
A lot of deleted scenes too.
Like there was originally a very long
deleted scene of Thor, the Dark World,
where he makes an illusion of himself
wielding Thor's hammer being cheered on
by other asgardians till his mother Frigga
comes in and calls them on his bullshit.
They also had all those scenes of him
practicing with Thor's
hammer behind the scenes.
It sounds like it
just at various times early on.
Marvel Phase one, Phase two, Phase three.
They thought about having him wield
the hammer during the actual movies
and big fight scenes, but just excited
to see big moments like that
for like Chris Evans version
of Captain America in Avengers Endgame.
that was also
probably the right move, too.
Like if they would have had a bunch
more people
wielding the hammer in Marvel phase
one that they do,
it just wouldn't have hit as hard
during Avengers Endgame.
There are a couple
brand new scenes of Sylvie and Mobius
behind the scenes, looking happily
at something next
to some regular looking house on earth.
This could be back in the 1980s where they
find Sylvie working at that McDonald's,
I'm not sure
which time periods they travel to.
We've only seen a couple of them
during the trailers.
noticed during the scene of them
laughing with kahui quand.
That's between scenes, obviously,
but you can actually see in the background
there's still rolling cameras,
like things in the background
are still active.
There's like a package
that falls behind them into the basket,
like some kind of weird delivery system.
They have the whole thing with his
character is that he's called Ora Burrows,
which translates to Time Eater,
but they call him Obi for short
and he's meant to have helped.
He who remains can create the TVA
when it first started
in all the technology
that they use like he's the main tech guy,
he created
pretty much everything that they use.
but it is based on iterations
of King's own technology,
which itself is an evolution of quantum
based energy technology.
that's why all the king variants, portals,
the TVA portals are the same
color is Ant-Man's
Quantum portal during Avengers Endgame
because they're both using quantum energy
to power all their tech,
the only major difference
is that all of King's Tech,
like all the King variance, is just
many thousands of years more advanced.
The whole idea with all king variants is
that each one comes from the 30th century.
They updated his origin story
a little bit in the more recent comics.
And the difference in the Marvel
comic book version of King
is that
he has a bunch of different personas
that he uses across
different time periods.
But in the MCU,
they're saying that
all the different personas
are just different variants
from other universes.
but most King variants begin
life in the 30th century.
And in that time period, there's no
more war, no more hunger, no more strife.
And it is boring
is it could possibly be so king
as a child grows really bored and finds
this abandoned Dr.
Doom museum in an active doom.
But then he steals Dr.
Doom's time travel platform plans
and uses them to travel back into the past
and set himself up
as the Rama Tut version of the character
ruling over ancient Egypt.
there are a couple of Easter eggs
for this during the new Knight series
and we saw a rama version of King
in the Council of Kings
and then in the WASP
Quantumania Post-Credits scene.
the Fantastic Four learn what he's doing
travel back to ancient Egypt to stop him.
Eventually he gives up, sets up
the mutant apocalypse as his successor
and escapes to the distant future,
where he reinvents himself as Kang
the conker in that persona travels back
to the past again to fight the Avengers
and just does it over and over again
under different personas.
like I said, though,
the MCU is just saying
that all those different personas
are actually different kings
from other universes.
So like the Rama Tut
version of Kang
is from a different universe
than Kang the Conqueror
from the amortized version of Kang Victor.
Timely, Dr.
Doom Kang, The Lizard King,
all from other universes.
The funny thing about Lizard King to early
theory is that he's from a universe
based on Andrew Garfield's
Amazing Spider-Man movie, where the Lizard
was successful in evolving
everybody on Earth into lizards.
They had a couple jokes
about this during Spider-Man.
No way home.
Let me know in the comments
if we're going to see a couple different
king variants during Loki Season two.
Which other variants
do you want to see bigger.
Minor, though, is that Loki Season
2 Episode 1 starts next week.
Remember they moved episodes to Thursday
nights 6 p.m.
Pacific Time, so my episode videos work
a little bit like the Ahsoka episode videos
they'll post like the next morning
which will be Friday mornings for Loki
Click here for my new
Ahsoka Episode 7 video and click here
for all my Loki videos.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!